now of course I'm guessing that lots of
people are asking you about Star Wars
today it seems to be a topic of interest
I can't imagine why I have no clue
either I mean it's I don't even know
what it's about have you seen them I
mean I've had Syd was like a couple of
movies or something I they're probably
not that good yeah so yeah
there's been a lot of you questions
about Star Wars and which ones would you
like to have been your favorite
questions if you've have been putting to
you today well some some crowd favorites
are the will I be involved in the
upcoming saga or trilogy or
what-have-you and to which I respond
maybe if I were to get involved it would
be strictly from a production point of
view as that is where I have my
interests I've been drawn by no pressure
from my father whatsoever he would
support me if I wanted to take over the
garbage industry but if anything I'd be
on a production side and probably
uncredited just because having another
Lucas on that is touchy JJ Abrams
contempt you into donning another
costume or maybe joining the dark side
if anyone could convince me it's JJ he's
a terrifically animated person and he's
extremely talented and between him and
the guidelines might have said I have no
doubt that the next three movies are
gonna be great since we're talking about
the future at the moment what would you
like to see if you could you know wave a
magic wand and have anything happen in
the future Star Wars Episode seven eight
and nine what would you ideally love to
see as a fan or someone who's been
involved in the past that's a tough
question to answer because entities you
guys more I already know what happens
Phil
that can't happen but I so I don't know
I'm happy with what's gonna happen is
that an answer can that be a thing I
mean I I would like to see it following
a new generation I'm not saying that's
what happens I'm saying that's what I
would like because to me
these next movies are about the next
generation as the prequels are about a
new generation and the originals were
for that generation and so I think I
think following a new generation and a
new group of heroes and villains well I
think that's the right move to make and
I think that's where I wanted to go how
about guys in the party are coming back
we've heard people like Mark Hamill and
Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher have
been muted is coming back I mean they
the kind of people you'd like to see
what do you think about them making a
comeback I mean again I think it would
be awesome like who doesn't want to see
on solo cruise throne the Falcon again
but at the same time maybe he's teaching
his son how to drive on it I don't know
so yeah again it's it'd be great to see
them dawn the dawn the costumes I would
I would nerd out definitely
I still do when I see them from time
and now have you been seeing any other
kind of speculation because obviously
it's a it's so massive Star Wars people
so loved it over the years and can't
wait to see what JJ was gonna be doing
with it as well there's loads of
speculation everywhere all over the
press all fans on the Internet
do you ever kind of see you have a
sneaky peek what's your favorite rumor
that's been out there haven't really
lately just gives up my job I've really
been able to follow some of the rumors
but there's been a couple pretty
fantastic ones however I think that
where my aunt does I think
JJ is a he's a guy who likes to people
keep people guessing there we go he'll
tease you and taunt you every which way
and then take you take you for a ride
and left just come out of nowhere so
it'll be interesting to see how that
plays out there's a couple of fantastic
roommates you seen what were the most
fantastic one let's see there was one I
don't know who came up with this that my
dad was gonna be starring in it I was
interesting
there's one that there's been a there's
been my rumors of which I thought were
pretty crazy like some of the actors
from Star Trek we're gonna play in Star
Wars which I know would never happen and
then one where they're they like collide
which was interesting but I don't think
that's gonna happen either I mean you
mentioned whether than any answers from
Star Trek to be install was of course
there was a whole rumor as well about
whether Benedict Cumberbatch dropped out
of one movie I think was it with Toto I
think if my memory serves you right so
that he could be in Star Wars so of
course there's so many Benedict
Cumberbatch around out there so many
Star Trek fans so many JJ Abrams I'm
sure they would live to see that happen
I mean what would you think about
happens I I don't know if I'd be so
thrilled I don't I think they're
probably I think that'd be the beginning
of the apocalypse - if you were to cross
Star Trek or Star Wars I don't think I
think it's a dangerous combination but I
mean again it would it would be
interesting it's an idea to explore if
anything just because it took place a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
maybe they found time travel I don't
know like there's there's a way that it
could work if anything in a video game
but it could be interesting it's
definitely a thought few worlds
colliding which one would come off best
would they both implode they would they
would probably both employ their just be
oh man
I don't even know what would happen it's
boggles the mind and of course is loads
of speculation out there is this that
it's gonna be in it is that it's gonna
be in here we hear that some people are
auditioning for I think at the other day
I heard I'm brilliant young Irish
actress Saoirse Ronan was auditioned for
it so she's a great actress I mean you'd
like to see her in it
I would I mean I I like that there
they're not going mainstream with it and
they're they're keeping to the the
conduct if you will that my dad kind of
applied to all his movies except for you
couldn't escape Harrison but new faces
and I hundred percent subscribed to that
because when you see someone like Brad
Pitt not to say he's not a brilliant
actor I love them but he kind of fits a
certain description like you see he's
like this kind of cool guy who's also a
badass he's and that is that in
everything and like there's all these
guys that are kind of in that and
everything Robert Downey jr. is
eccentric but also touching see that and
everything and so to bring in a new face
something you just can't expect it's
it's a good it's good philosophy to
testify were you surprised when your
dad's kind of said probably you know
gone as far as I want to go in our Star
Wars and kind of passed the baton on you
know I wasn't only because I knew that
he he was very torn on the matter he
wanted to he was like it was like a kid
who had turned 18
ready to leave the house never parent
I'm up here parent or not but most every
parent I've encountered anyways has
wanted to let their children go but at
the same time and they leave but I'm
gonna hold on to you until you actually
leave and so I think that's where he's
at with that I think he's ready to let
it go and let it grow did he talk about
him and the family before he kind of
made a final decision a little bit I
mean we knew probably a year prior he
had started writing and kind of
researching and starting his whole
little process and about halfway through
that process is when the Disney the idea
of selling to Disney came up and so that
once those two collided that's when he
kind of sat down said I'm having to do
this but he didn't really he just kind
of mentioned it off handedly like it
wasn't a big deal like we were eating
dinner or I was eating dinner I wasn't
even with him he called me just like a
normal conversations like asked how he
was doing and it was like I started
writing and I was like oh like you know
you're little like whatever you're
focusing on now is like no Star Wars and
such and then like moved on I was like
let's back up let's back up like a
sentence what are you writing now and so
that's when he kind of dropped that bomb
and it was it was nice because he's he's
happiest when he's writing and when he's
doing something with this time and so it
was it was nice to hear I think he'll
still keep a kind of watchful eye over
what happens with it yeah I don't think
I mean as any parent watching their kid
go to college
he he will definitely heat he's
constantly talking with JJ and obviously
JJ was hand-picked and he's there he's
it there to guide whenever and it will
help where he can but at the same time
like I said he wants to let it go and
become its new generation with a new
generation of a director that knew
everything what do you think about JJ as
a choice for to carry that massive and
they'll carry that flame forward
I love JJ he's an awesome guy he was he
was at my parents wedding he we have
known him many many years I love what he
did with Star Trek's by what some people
think I think he's an absolutely like
the most talented director the only guy
who'd be able to do this and working
with the people he's working with the
Disney as well as Lucasfilm same thing
now
I mean he's it's a
it's an ease and all how tough is it for
you and other people kind of who know
what is going on for sure in the
production to kind of keep things under
wraps because obviously you're at things
like this people are asking questions I
mean is answer is it pressure you grip
you gain as a skin for it if you will
there's it's it's fun actually because
people throw around speculations and
some of them are ID and some of them are
wrong some of them are close and you
just kind of you just kind of have to
sit there and say but it's it's it's
interesting and it's obviously people
are always asking questions but we like
to maintain as much as possible the
ability for someone to actually
experience it not knowing what's
happening because that's the best way to
experience anything especially Star Wars
and following Allegiant ask you a little
bit about what it's like acting in this
yeah there's a little movies that some
people might have heard of oh it was a
lot of fun I trained for two weeks prior
with Nick Gillard the stunt coordinator
who's a great guy and I was fortunate
enough to be training right around the
time Hayden and Ewan were practicing and
training for they're like the most epic
duel ever
and so I got a little distracted from
times
but I mean it was it was a lot of fun I
got really close with Hayden he was like
a big brother to me
and I actually just got son see him at
the wedding for the first time in like
10 years
and it was like a reuniting is it was
awesome and what can we look forward to
happening with you in the future you
mentioned producing oh yeah well
hopefully yeah I'm working on a TV show
now Chicago Fire it's over in Chicago
and I'm just kind of learning from the
bottom up we look forward to following
that and thanks so much for talking to
us we look forward to finding out what's
right what is it in the speculation
thanks Jeff thank you
you